добрый день друзья сегодня мы начинаем
самую важную технологию для достижения
успеха это оказион планирование и мы
сегодня рассмотрим не только каждом
планирования мы в этом курсе рассмотрим
power management кластеризацию мы
рассмотрим отличия к 1 планирование от
других систем планирования мы рассмотрим
более подробно уже сам power management
из чего он состоит и ли управление
энергией мы рассмотрим эти приложения
необходимый для того чтобы заниматься
академ планированием и мы рассмотрим
практику кайзен планирования основная
цель нашего курса каждом планирования и
power management как основа счастливой
жизни заключается в том чтобы вам дать
окончательный полный инструмент
планирования и исполнения своих задач и
дел и достижения всех ваших жизненных
целей
поверьте мне я это могу утверждать
основываясь на всем моем многолетнем
опыте которую основан на том что я всю
жизнь занимаюсь планированием
я люблю планировать это мое любимое
занятие и я все время совершенствуют
систему планирования в каждом
планирование
сошлось все и технология кольца и
тайм-менеджмент и туду и различные
программы по оптимизации выполнения дел
и по контролю дел и так далее так далее
здесь собрано все что я когда-либо читал
здесь собрано все о чем я когда-либо
думал
чем я занимался и так далее это самая
важная часть достижения успеха самая
важная часть повторюсь сразу должен
заметить курс достаточно большой и это
не теоретический курс
а именно практический курс потому что
если вы не намерены внедрять к одним
планирование в свою жизнь то скорее
всего этот курс для вас будет скучным
но если вы шаг за шагом внедрить эту
технологию то я вам гарантирую что ваша
жизнь в
не будет прежней и вы будете жить
успешной наполненной смыслом и
счастливой жизнью и так приступаем мы
сейчас рассмотрим первый модуль курс
состоит из 6 модулей первый модуль это
что такое планирование к 1 планирования
и его важность
второе кальцием планирования и его
отличие от других систем планирования 3
сам уже описание самого каждом
планирования четвертое это третье
описание козин планет и еще как
планировать сразу с практическими
техниками 4 и the power management
пятое найти приложение для кальцием
планирования и для power менеджмента и
шестое практика казим планирования и или
дополнительные инструменты которые
дополняют и обогащают кальцием
планирование и который помогает вам
применять каждый из этих инструментов в
ежедневной жизни там будет рассказано в
каких случаях как что и применять итак
начинаем модуль первый урок 1
предыстория плановой
я всю жизнь занимаюсь планированием как
я говорил вам до этого это вообще мой
любимый предмет
это то чем я всю жизнь все время
занимался причем с детства я сам
закончил казахскую школу и два года
работал чабаном потом отслужил в армии
после армии пришел в университет им не
нужна была гарантирована
сдать экзамены и поступить в университет
ну какие шансы у парня саула который
закончил тем более казахскую школу
поступить в то время казгу
элитный университеты я еще пытался
поступить на юридический факультет это
был самый элитный факультет к моему
счастью к тому моменту пришла первая
волна демократии
пришел колбин заместо кунаева я в данном
случае горка моему счастью про
демократию они про колбина чтобы вы меня
правильно поняли так вот первая волна
демократии и набором университеты пошли
и начали делаться очень прозрачным путем
было даже так что
родители стояли на улице а на камеру
снимали процесс как абитуриенты сдают
экзамены мы брали билет зачитывали его
и потом наш ответ тоже на камеру
снимался и на улице родителям мониторе
видели наш ответ то есть это был наверно
истории казахстана самый честный
объективный набор хотя результатом этого
набора стало то что средний возраст
моего курса был 32 года можете признать
32 года этот средний возраст моего курса
так вот я пришел я должен был поступить
гарантированную в казгу наир faq и
что я сделал я подошел преподавателем по
четырем предметом и спросил у каждого из
них что я должен прочитать чтобы успешно
сдать ваш экзамен
вот как вы сами считаете что я должен
знать дайте мне список пожалуйста книг
ну они мне дали списке литературы
я пошел в библиотеку взял эти книги и
поставил их на стол 4 стопки первое что
сделал я посчитал странице после этого
составил список и читал ровно неделю
посмотрел степень своей усвояемости
оказалось что я эффективно усваиваю в
день 50 страниц соответственно если я
утром читаю и вечером повторяют а эти 50
страниц у меня хорошо укладывались в
голове
например по истории мне надо прочесть
там тысячу сто пятьдесят страниц
если все учебники сложить 1150 страниц
то есть тысяча сто пятьдесят страниц я
делю на 50 равно 23 дня
плюс я беру недельный запас на всякий
случай плюс три дня до самого экзамена
чтобы отдохнуть и за 33 дня я должен
приступить к этой стопке я сделал график
и спокойно беззаботно ходил свое
удовольствие ждал пока наступит это
время ну конечно я утрирую что
ждал я просто готовился по-своему то
есть я выставил все стопки
взял первую стопку и начинал и спеша
готовиться пока не раз упали дэдлайны по
другим предметам
и вот когда наступал дедлайн я начинал
читать по вечерам мы обычно играли
футбол с друзьями и а я стоял на воротах
я не люблю общем перед после армии меня
полностью отбили все желание бегать и
поэтому я защищал ворота а в 7 часов
вечера я все бросил все бросал и уходил
потому что у меня было повторение и у
меня постоянно друзья спрашивают ну куда
ты пошел до конца игры оставалось там
минут 15 потерпи и так далее я говорю
нет у меня сейчас повторение и так это
повторялось несколько раз три-четыре
раза и вот однажды они как-то собрались
и говорят ну блин ты запарил уже скажи
что за повторение у тебя что там такое
что за система
ну и я им объясняю понимаете гору это
такая система при которой я все выставил
дедлайны и я должен утром читать 50
страниц вечером повторять если я пропущу
что-то то я толком не у свою и они
начали спрашивать ну и какие у тебя
планы дальнейшую игру планы сдать на
отлично все предметы
а дальше я гуру стать ленинским
стипендиатом а дальше а дальше закончу
университет с красным дипломом ну они
все дружно заржали
надо мной смеялись как над болтоном хотя
внешность у меня явно не ботанская и с
тех пор у меня прилепилось кликуха или
кличка плановой я добыл довольно свои
клички потому что этого плановое то
человек который у которого есть планы на
все случаи жизни ну думаю нормально
кличко но я тогда по своей наивности не
знал что плановой у городских ребята
знать обозначает
наркомана наркоман который курит план
марихуану
но я очень долгое время ходил и гордился
этой кличкой плановой прошло много лет
но планирования не бросил и более того я
даже его усовершенствовал я очень много
времени трачу на него каждое утро каждый
день каждую неделю каждый месяц каждый
год это вообще мое природное качество
так вот каждый свой день я начинаю с
планирование каждую неделю ночная
спланировать каждый месяц и каждый год
мне это не трудно и очень даже комфортно
мне некомфортно жить без плана
так вот при этом моя система
планирования которой я вам расскажу
позже никак не отделима от моей
повседневной жизни это не так что планы
моей живут со своей жизнью я живу своей
жизнью я уже выстрел систем планируем
таким образом что я бесплатно
практически не делаю почти ничего я
скажу почему я сказал почти это не
оговорка
есть определенный круг дел такие как
одна шаговые дела я их называю или
двухшаговый дела простые которые я не
планирую а перевожу на привычки либо
которые я не планировал о перевожу на
ролевое поведение
об этом мы тоже пройдем и поговорим то
есть планирую я в основном это сложные
дела и
многоходовые дела так вот планирование
для меня лично планируем воспринимается
как зрение вот я даже не могу
представить себе жизнь без зрения или
для тех кто более понимает другую другой
предмет пример скажу это планирование то
как фары дальнего света
у автомобиля чем дальше свет ваш бьет
тем комфортнее вам ехать и вы тем лучше
понимаете и разбирайтесь куда вам ехать
поэтому планируем системы планирования
это та система которая освещает ваш путь
и не даёт вам провалиться в кредиты или
удариться в столб и так далее вот
воспринимайте это так это очень важно
потому что если у вас нету системы
планирования то вы будете как крот у
которого вы знаете не зрение
постоянно упираться в какие-то проблемы
в какие-то препятствия и так далее по
мере своего занятия бизнесом да и вообще
по мере
течение моей жизни я продолжал все время
размышлять и все время но я находил
какие-то недостатки в системах
планирования я начинал свое время вот с
такого бумажного
ежедневника дневника все записывал и
планировал итак итак тогда еще
смартфонов не было на календарях писал
что только intel но потом начал печатать
свои календари
вы вкратце таким образом я путем
многократного анализа размышлений и
многократных совершенствования я пришел
к современные вот той системе козин
планирование и power менеджмента которую
я вам буду теперь представлять на этом
курсе я эту систему планирования
опробовал как в бизнесе
так и в общественной деятельности так и
в сфере инвестиции такие в сфере личной
жизни нельзя считать что это система
планирования для бизнес-деятельности то
есть для бизнеса
остальная жизнь вашим может идти без
планах абсолютно не так система
планирования кайден планер не она
покрывает все аспекты вашей жизни это
планирование всей вашей жизни а не
какого-то бизнеса либо общественных дел
если вы досконально изучите
и внедрите в свою жизнь эту систему то
вы увидите что во все стороны вашей
жизни у вас как бы как как будто
откроется второе зрение и вы будете
передвигаться не на ощупь будете
вступать
уверенными шагами и вы почувствуете
контроль над своей жизнью
присмотрите что такое контроль контроль
это прежде всего предсказуемость
прежде всего предсказуемость и если вы
будете руководство системой кайзен
планирования то ваша жизнь приобретёт
предсказуемый характер все события
которые будут с вами происходить
они будут событиями которые вы заранее
предусмотрели или которые вы заранее
запланировали при этом очень важно
отметить вы будете выполнять огромное
количество дел просто огромное
количество дел по сравнению с тем
вы делали раньше причем большинство
ваших дел будут именно
завершенными делами потому что цель
любой системы планирования заключается в
том чтобы увеличить количество
завершенных дел они начатых дел значит
начать любое дело проект легко проблема
же всегда в завершении еще очень важно
что по мере завершения дел или
выполнение огромного количества дел вы
не будете терять силы энергии и
энтузиазма
выполнению задач станет для вас приятным
стимулирующим занятием у вас появится
азарт и вы навсегда забудете что такое
апатия депрессия упадок сил и
прокрастинация вообще основной секрет
эффективности моей системы состоит в том
что дела выполняются по мере
необходимости проблемы решаются по мере
их поступления все задачи выстроены в
поток и падают подаются к выполнению в
нужное время при этом система направлена
на поддержание высокого уровня вашей
энергии в течение всего времени мы с
вами начнем изучение к 1 планирование с
ключевых и основополагающих тем почему
планирование важно в целом для всех
людей и всех ситуаций как планирование
соотносится со счастьем воли и действием
ведь и даже и затронуть эти аспекты
можно ли планировать потоки и превратить
планирование в поток а далее мы будем
детально рассматривать саму систему
ее отличие от известных вам всех систем
планирования и их преимущество ее
преимущества и недостатки и конечно же
практическое применение в жизни ну и
конечно же
айти приложение как же без этого это
вступительный урок для того чтобы вы
поняли о чем будет речь
к чему готовиться и если вы готовы
изменить кардинально свою жизнь тогда
поехали